the way that the refs are calling the
ref and the passer calls it is
definitely crazy man the commanders
versus the Patriots right here I mean
what else can you do right here I don't
know it's insane man for you to take
this sack away from him I think that was
his first sack of the year like he's a
young kid right he gets a sack and does
the right things knee broke fall he
rolls forward doesn't roll like he
doesn't bomb the quarterback and it's
2023 you can easily see that on the
screen and say like like okay yeah I
called the flag but it really wasn't a
flag like I'm just going to pick it up
it feels like for defense you got 14
people against you 11 on offense and two
or three reps that are out get you for
defensive holding or roughing the passer
any given college but every couple weeks
it seems like it's one hit that seems
normal that gets either a flag or more
from it and it's like at some point I
defensive player you you like Lord but
who looking out for us